HRISHIKESH ARADHYE: Hi
everyone, my name is Hrishi.
I'm one of the engineering
directors in the Android
and the Play teams.
I honestly feel like I lucked
into one of the coolest jobs
at Google.
There's a lot of activity
going on in the space.
I promised myself a beer
every time someone mentioned
AI or machine
learning, and it seems
like at the end of
the day I'm going
to be very, very drunk at the
rate things are going today.
So it's no secret that if you've
been following our narrative
in the last couple of I/Os,
a few hardware announcements,
that Google's
heavily banking on AI
and machine learning as one of
the core pillars of our product
development.
And there is a reason for that.
You have heard our
CEO mention before
that we used to be a
mobile-first company,
and now we at an
AI-first company.
And I wanted to give you
some context into how
we evolved into that vision.
So come to think about
it, in retrospect,
it is easy to
imagine what it meant
to be a mobile-first product.
A mobile-first product is a
product that is fundamentally
designed for a small screen.
It is fundamentally
designed for a product that
has always-on connectivity.
It is fundamentally designed
for low-power usage,
and so on and so forth.
So we believe that
products of tomorrow
will take some of these
other things for granted.
So products of
today, for example,
it's hard to imagine
an app that is not
designed with some of the
principles I mentioned
in the mobile-first column.
Five years down, I think
products of tomorrow
will have to have some
of these other factors
in the AI-first column.
So products of
tomorrow, we believe,
will be required
to learn and adapt,
will be expected to learn
and adapt from user behavior.
We believe the
products of tomorrow
should assist the user in doing
that in a [INAUDIBLE] better.
We believe the
products of tomorrow
should be conversational
and assistant.
So products of
tomorrow should be
able to figure out if
they don't know anything
and they should be
able to ask the user
for the right information.
Products of tomorrow should
also be context aware.
They should be aware of the
state of the environment.
They should be aware of
the state of the user.
And they should be
using that information
to make that product better.
And last but not the
least, products of tomorrow
should be trustworthy
in a fundamental way.
And that's not just about
safety, security, and privacy,
but also being able
to deliver performance
that is reliable on day
one and on day hundred.
So with that in mind,
machine learning
is a fundamental
set of algorithms
that help our products
and our platforms
get closer to that vision.
I say here on this slide
that machine learning
is the science and the art
of making machines learn.
Your products shouldn't
just be great on day one
but should be even
better on day hundred.
And machine learning
will help you get there.
So as a learning
example, I picked an app,
a hypothetical app, that will
take a picture of an animal
and let you classify
it as a dog or a cat.
And in the world
of yesterday, you
would develop this system by
designing a bunch of heuristics
based on human knowledge of
what separates a dog and a cat.
And you would just encode that
knowledge in a bunch of rules.
But real world is
much messier than that
and very unpredictable.
So your set of rules
might work for 10 images,
20 images, 100 images.
But as you start to gather
hundreds of thousands
of images, all kinds of
corner cases pile up.
And it becomes really
hard and intractable
for a rule-based
system to evolve.
So before I took
this new gig on,
I ran search and discovery for
the Play Store for four years.
And even our [INAUDIBLE] stack
started with a rule-based way.
And as our product
started to grow,
it became harder and harder
to evolve it over time.
And so machine learning
comes to the rescue.
So compared to
rule-based systems,
machine-learning systems take
a completely different approach
to solving some of
the same problems.
So here is a simple
schematic of something
called a neural network.
It's called a neural
network because it
mimics the processing
of our brain
and tries to achieve it
with software systems.
So the way this works
is given a picture,
and given millions
of such pictures,
it will take the
pixels of that picture
and then follow through
with layers of computation
to allow us to
predict at the end
whether it was a cat or a dog.
It doesn't start
with a hardcoded set
of rules that embed our
knowledge about cats and dogs.
Instead, it learns or relies on
millions of samples and data.
And with every sample it gets
better and better and better
at doing that job.
So back in 2011 on some
of the standard data
sets around computer
vision, around recognizing
objects and images, we
had around 26% error rate.
Compare that error rate
with humans, about 5%.
So you could imagine
that at that time,
we would be lucky if we could
classify a picture as indoor
versus outdoor.
But we weren't too good
at reliably recognizing
what's in the picture.
So today, these systems
based on deep neural networks
are even better than
human-level performance.
It's a 3% error rate.
And perceptually it
feels like we are now
able to see the world
through machines.
And that enables a whole
lot of other things,
other cool things we could
do with software systems.
And it's not just about labeling
pictures as a cat or dog,
but we can automatically
caption them
with really
human-sounding captions.
So I show some of
the examples here.
The left hand side top
picture says a close up
of a child holding
a stuffed animal.
So if you think about it,
there are many parameters that
goes into a label like that.
We not only detect that
there is a young child
and a stuffed animal
in the picture,
we detect that the child
is holding the animal
and that it's a close up.
So there are multiple
layers of intelligence
built into a caption like that.
And there are many
cool examples here
that really showcase
how the technology has
evolved over time.
The scientists in
me would cringe
if I hadn't put even a
single example of a mislabel.
You can see that
the bottom row says
a man flying through the
air riding a snowboard,
and it's clearly not that.
So AI systems today
are much better
compared to where
they used to be,
but they're still not perfect.
And any product you
design with AI in mind
has to be aware of that.
So the types of
problems ML can solve--
I want to give
you a quick flavor
for the types of use cases
you might be able to power
with ML and AI.
So the first example
is classification.
And it's similar to
what I showed before.
Take a picture, label
it as a cat or dog.
Take a song, label it as
a pop song or a rock song.
Or take an app and label
it as a harmful app or not.
And these are some of the
examples of classification.
Take an item and label
it within the namespace.
Another example is prediction.
So here I show YouTube
recommendations for videos
to watch if you're
watching this video.
So machine-learning systems
are getting really better
at predicting user activity.
If you watch this video, given
the knowledge of other users
who watched the
same video before,
are you able to reliably
predict which video they're
going to use next?
And the third example--
sorry, how do I go back--
is perception.
Machine-learning systems
are getting better at not
just labeling and
predicting but also
being able to understand
the world through images,
through sound, through
audio, and through
natural-language processing.
Here I show an example
of system integration,
and I know you'll be hearing
about that through the day.
So a few examples
of where Google's
used ML technology over
the few years-- so Google
has a wide array of products.
Some of these products, seven
products, are used by a billion
plus monthly active users a day.
And many of them fundamentally
use machine learning.
An example here is Google Lens.
This is one of the recent
examples of machine learning
has fundamentally changed the
way products behave today.
So you are able to not
only detect landmarks
but are able to do
that in real time
in the viewfinder of
the camera, and perceive
the real-time imagery
through machines.
Next example is machine-learned
personalized recommendations.
Coby mentioned that ML is used
heavily for recommendations
on the app store.
Here I show examples
from YouTube.
So given your
video-watch history,
what videos make the
most sense for you?
Another example is
Google Translate
where you can look at
the picture in real time,
detect not only the
text in the picture,
detect the language it's
in, and able to recognize
that all in real time.
Another example is smart
reply in Gmail and Inbox.
We can process the
text of the message
and are able to predict what the
likely response is going to be.
So for someone like me running
from meeting to meeting trying
to respond to messages on the
staircase, this sort of feature
is super useful.
And last but not the
least, this is an example
where it's not a user-facing
application at all
but our ability to optimize
back-end processing in data
centers.
So using DeepMind AI from
our office in London,
we were able to reduce our power
usage in Google's data centers
by up to 40%.
So Google not only built
some of these products
but we also have some of
the most-used platforms
in the world today.
And it's not sufficient
for our own products
to get better with AI and ML.
We also want to
empower all of you
to use AI and ML in your
own products as well.
So to do that, we
open sourced some
of the fundamental
parts of our ML stack
through TensorFlow
several years ago.
And this is a repository in
GitHub that anyone of you
can download and use.
It's getting huge traction
in the developer community
already.
Just in two years this
graph shows the GitHub stars
for TensorFlow compared to other
such repositories out there.
And it has just been
exceedingly popular
and getting used more and more.
We are not going to
stop there though.
So TensorFlow, when it was open
sourced a couple of years ago,
it was fundamentally
designed for server use case.
And at I/O this
year we announced
that we are taking
it to work on device.
So TensorFlow Lite,
which is going
to be a fast and efficient
version of TensorFlow, going
to be open sourced this quarter,
will be instance of TensorFlow
that runs on Android devices.
And last but not
least, we are not only
making it possible for
you to use ML libraries
but we are also
making it possible
for you to directly access
Google's intelligent APIs.
So example here is detecting
faces and emotions in faces
through Google's Cloud ML
APIs and some of the same APIs
that are available
on device as well.
So that's it.
I'll be available for
taking some other questions
later down the day.
And I know we have a deeper
dive on ML during the day.
Thank you all.